we're told the function f is twice
differentiable with f of 2 equals 1 f
prime of 2 is equal to 4 and f prime
prime of 2 is equal to 3. what is the
value of the approximation of f of 1.9
using the line tangent to the graph of f
at x equals two so pause this video and
see if you can figure this out this is
an actual question from a past ap
calculus exam
all right now let's do this together and
if i was actually doing this on exam i
would just cut to the chase and i would
figure out the equation of the tangent
line at x equals to go through the point
two comma one and then i would figure
out okay when x is equal to 1.9 what is
the value of y and that would be my
approximation but but for the sake of
learning and getting the intuition here
let's just make sure we understand
what's happening so let me graph this
so let's say that's my
y-axis
and then this is my
x-axis and this is x equals 1 this is x
equals 2 this is y equals 1. we know
that the point 2 comma 1 is on the graph
of y is equal to f x so we know that
point right over there is there and we
also know the slope of the tangent line
the slope of the tangent line is 4. so
it's going to look something like this
it's going to probably even be a little
steeper than that the slope of the
tangent line is going to look something
like that
and we don't know much more about we
know the second derivative here but what
they're asking us to do is without
knowing what the function actually looks
like the function might look something
like this let me just draw something
so the function
might look
might look something like this
we're trying to figure out what f of 1.9
is so if x is 1.9 f of 1.9 if that's the
way the function actually looked might
be this value right over here but we
don't know for sure because we don't
know much more about the function but
what they're suggesting for us to do is
use this tangent line if we know the
equation of this tangent line here we
can say well what does that tangent line
equal when x equals 1.9 when x equals
1.9 it equals that point right over
there and then we could use that as our
approximation for f of 1.9 well to do
that we know we need to know the
equation of the tangent line and we
could do that in point slope form we
would just have to say y minus the y
value that we know is on that line the
point 2 comma 1 we know is on that line
so y minus 1 is going to be equal to the
slope of our tangent line which we know
is going to be equal to 4
times x minus the x value that
corresponds to that y value so x minus
2. so now we just have to substitute x
equals 1.9 to get our approximation for
f of 1.9 so we'd say y minus 1 is equal
to 4 times
1.9 minus 2. 1.9 minus 2 is negative 0.1
and let's see 4 times negative 0.1 this
all simplifies to negative 0.4 now you
add 1 to both sides you get y is equal
to if you add 1 here you're gonna get
0.6 so this it's i didn't draw it quite
to scale 0.6 might be something closer
to right around there but there you go
it that is our approximation for f of
1.9 which is choice b and we're done and
one interesting thing to note is we
didn't have to use all the information
they gave us we did not have to use this
information about the second derivative
in order to solve the problem so if you
ever find yourself in that situation
don't doubt yourself too much because
they will sometimes give you unneeded
information